Hello Freak bitches.
But it's just like those same people who will be like a year like against women,
like I would never in a million years go out to a show and be like,
I'm just rooting for the men today.
Like,
like I,
I don't think this way.
I'm not like on team man,
but you are on team women.
Like it's just,
it just seems to me that there's a lot of that going on.
You know what I mean?
A lot of that shit where it's like you kind of projected this thing that you see
racism everywhere or you see sexism everywhere.
But all I really see is you fucking lecturing people based on race and send
their mind.
They're allowed to do it the same way Cain Velasquez allowed to have brown pride
and his chest kind of same thing.
Like you'll,
you're disenfranchised or you're marginalized so you're allowed to stay.
Even if you're not,
you playing that victim card as a woman and you're allowed to say,
I'm here to support my girl.
Like I was talking about this on stage of the day.
I saw a bumper sticker on a car.
It said girls kick ass.
And I was like,
some of them,
yeah,
some of them are lazy slobs.
I like what are you gonna Align yourself with?
150 million women just in this country alone.
That's ridiculous.
And I was saying if a guy had a bumper sticker,
it said boys kick ass.
He be like follow that guy and find out where he's been fucking these kids.
Cause he,
first of all,
you never say boys,
boys kick ass.
You put that on your bumper.
So where the fuck are you?
You'd pull them over.
Let me see your license.
Where do you live man?
What do you do for a living?
What's that bumper sticker about?
What the fuck do you mean by that?
And I don't need,
like I almost feel like an asshole sometimes where I preface everything with a
disclaimer like,
and I'm not saying this and I'm not,
but I just want it to be clear that I'm not saying there aren't exceptions to
the rule,
but it's also kind of strange to me that like if you want to celebrate women,
why are you celebrating such a masculine quality?
Like it's kind of like,
it's like,
look,
there are white players who are great basketball players,
right?
There are white.
The Dark Novitsky was an amazing basketball player,
but if I just wrote somewhere like white people kick ass at basketball,
it's like,
well,
actually,
well this is that movie coming on in general.
Women don't kick ass in general.
Generally speaking,
that's a male thing to do.
I'm not saying there's not exceptions to that,
but you're like,
you're writing white people kick ass in basketball.
It's kind of misleading.
They don't have the same feelings about cultural appropriation as some people do
with fucking braids.
Yeah,
yeah.
I get it.
Well,
but it's the United States,
right?
We're sending over super sensitive.
We've gotten various senses.
You know what it is,
it all comes from a litigious culture that's,
oh absolutely.
The fact that you can get sued for anything anybody can sue you at anytime.
That's just like,
that's American culture.
That's what you do.
And it's like,
you know what,
you pissed off someone like enough,
you can sue them.
And so there's a lot of like suing,
swinging,
swinging enough successful cases along the way.
That's part of,
it's like a fear based operating system.
Right.
Hauling people on Shit maybe they didn't even think was bad.
Yeah.
It's a combination of like someone,
like it's a good service to be able to sue someone if you needed to.
However it's abused up the Ying Yang and there's like professional lawyers,
they have billboards everywhere.
But do you think Katy Perry who was worried about being sued?
No,
I'm saying that I'm saying that the sensitivity issue,
like why,
why we're so white American culture is so like PC at this point because there's
a,
it kind of goes hand in hand.
It's like a sense of,
I dunno,
I'm,
I'm at a loss for words a little bit to stoned,
but,
but I will say it's having that litigious fear based kind of motivator or it
causes people to want to correct things like to correct course,
correct.
To,
uh,
to a form of something that works for everyone to avoid being sued too.
I mean,
not me,
not directly,
but that thought process.
Yeah.
That,
yeah,
that mindset.
I think that's because it's about like,
okay,
well how can we make this,
we have to include everybody on this,
which I believe in.
Yeah.
But absolutely.
But,
uh,
but I think it should be done out of a sense of empathy and not to say that,
that,
you know,
people fighting for rights to have handicap parking like in the front of the
building.
Like there's thing that's just a great idea.
But like,
I'm just saying that the,
what were you,
you were kind of referring to that sensitivity come,
comes from that where someone's like afraid of doing something wrong.
Yeah.
And it just starts feeding back and feeding back,
feeding back.
And then you get people so fearful of any choice that they're making.
Who Was it?
Was it Roosevelt who tried to,
no,
it was
southerners weren't lazy.
Just infected with hookworms.
A story of the postbellum south as told by parasites.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
It makes your teeth fall out and it needs more brain,
Huh?
Stereotypes are almost always the conclusion of Lazy Science.
They're just empirical generalizations that are stripped of their variances and
encoded as fact and to the collective consciousness of the general population.
They're the two Bubba,
blah,
blah.
However,
sometimes the stereotype reveals a hidden truth that provides an origin to the
myth.
The trope of the Lazy Southerner dates back to America's postbellum period
following the end of the civil war.
No one really knows where it came from,
but the image of [inaudible] filthy drawling farmer has pervaded art literature
and pop your culture until up until this very moment.
So one argument recently published by Rachel,
newer for PBS Nova tax present some compelling evidence for the theory that a
hookworm epidemic was responsible for the rural stereotype holding holy
shit.
Germ of laziness through the exhaustion mental fogginess attends to inflict upon
its victims.
Historical evidence shows that the parasite ravaged the American south
throughout the early 20th century as a result of poor sanitation and lack of
public health programs among the poor,
whole crazy by 1905 the parasite ologist.
That's a job.
I'm a joke.
Topologist Charles says,
as we have 40% or more,
not 60% I was wrong of the southern population was infected with hookworms.
The parasite thrives and fecal matter and the combination of shoddy waste
disposal in the rarity of shoes,
shoes,
no shoes allowed hookworm larvae to enter people's bodies through the webbing
between their toes.
How Fun.
Once they penetrate the skin,
they traveled through their hosts lungs into their intestines where they survive
on a diet of blood,
they suck out from the intestinal wall of female.
Hookworm can lay up to 10,000 eggs in a single day,
which gives you an idea of how ramping a localized infestation can become an a
very short time.
The laziness that is synonymous with hookworm.
Hookworm infections is a synonym of iron deficiency anemia due to blood loss.
Holy Shit.
Getting bled out.
Yes.
40% of people were anemic and had blood loss.
The poor malnourished victims,
the parasite can cause stunted growth.
That's right.
Uh,
children with hookworms,
we're plagued with attention deficit disorders,
lower Iq and the infected often had strange food cravings for dirt,
clay paper and chalk.
How nuts is that?
Southern states where the nexus of hookworm friendly climate is the parasite
loved the sandy soil that makes a real with the region.
So for at all,
in 1910,
7.5 million southerners had hookworms.
Oh my God.
How nuts is that?
That's insane.
Insane.
Yes.
Rockefeller is who donated money to try to combat it,
but dusty Illuminati,
isn't he like a,
maybe this is all scam,
50 years for the worm to be eradicated from the south.
1960 it was eradicated.
Oh my God.
Because of the sanitation issues.
Look at that.
Almost entirely freed from hookworms by 1985 yeah,
that was [inaudible] 20 years ago.
That's so recently.
It's completely insane.
Yeah.
Is that nuts?
It's never,
she's going to grab my head and forced me to eat her pussy.
Yeah,
great thought though,
isn't it?
Being made to do it.
That's one of my greatest turnout.
Stick your tongue
in your mouth
or have someone do that.
It was all right.
Not Bad.
Not that.
No.
I had a girl when I had to go and try it.
I tell you this,
she's trying to push a fart out and she shot monistat seven on my chest.
Oh,
fucking horrible.
Monistat seven or something.
Girls putting their vaginal infection.
Oh,
Jesus.
Not My best moment.
What it smell like?
I don't believe it had a smell.
I don't remember having a smell to explain that it was monistat.
I knew exactly what it was.
We both knew what it was,
you know?
No,
it was a bad,
it was a bad scene,
but she was really fucking sexy.
Big Fat ass.
Ooh.
Yeah.
It's just trying to fart on you.
I don't really care about that,
but I was like,
yeah,
why not?
Why aren't my face?
That's whose idea was it?
Mine.
I think she's,
I have to,
I'm like,
Hey,
what do you,
you already said you have to no,
no.
I think she saw I have to Fart.
Oh,
she said I have to Fart.
And you're like fire my mouth.
We had always done that.
Just licked her ass and she has a great app.
You know what I mean?
We were kind of from that.
Nah,
not that I know of.
Somebody must've terrible way to feel like,
why didn't I just shower up first?
I don't like to shower them up first.
I don't like the,
I like this.
I like a scent.
I literally like you like you're like a machine.
I like them.
I telling you like I'll tell him the girl I'm dating you and I like you.
I literally have thrown girlfriends,
deodorants out.
I fucking stink a little.
Yes,
but I have to fucking the way you're saying it.
but I have to like them.
Oh,
it has to be a key.
It's a chemistry thing that's nature telling you who you should fucking who you
shouldn't fuck.
Cause some people sent repulses me the smell of their mouth are the smaller
their skin repulses me unhealthy people probably.
Or even people that I'm just not meant to breed with.
But then there's some people,
the underarm smell,
the smell,
their feet when they're stinky.
Dude,
it makes me not dirty.
I don't like dirty feet.
Like I don't want you to talk a little stinky in socks and sneakers because it's
clean.
There's a whole fucking thing of it.
[inaudible].